included groundbreaking Asian Americans
like Vera Wang and and and Joan Shin
Gangnam Style
koala
this is the Reuben report I'm Dave Rubin
Chihuahua it is July 10 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
share subscribe tap that notification
Bell if you have not post game show as
always at
reubenreport.locals.com I got a fresh
haircut this morning I'm feeling good
the team was averaging out at about a
9-7 on this Monday we shall see before
we get going I want to tell you I did a
rare it's very rare that they can get me
to work on a weekend but I did a rare
Sunday interview yesterday finally sat
down with Robert F Kennedy Jr it was on
the Fly made it happen we will be
releasing it this week we went into
everything we really did we got into
what's happened to the Democrat Party we
got into some of our differences say on
affirmative action we got into the covid
stuff we talked Trump to santis the
craziness of the establishment like all
of it censorship everything uh so clips
and uh full thing coming out this week
stay tuned on that uh the theme of today
is racism
have you heard about this thing it's the
oldest hatred in the books and it's a uh
it's a crudgel I would say for not very
thoughtful people to shut down anyone
who disagrees with them on anything else
uh Dana White you know UFC president
Dana White uh heesh really really shut
down a reporter over the weekend who
tried to racialize one of his upcoming
fights and I thought it was a good frame
for what we could do today because it's
what the media does with virtually every
topic right it's usually about race but
now it can be about gender a couple
other little things instead of dealing
with the real issues of the day and how
do we really solve problems we just say
you're racist you're a bigot you're a
homophobe wrap it up but I don't think
that the average American in 2023 is
racist at all I don't think there's
virtually anyone that really wants
racist policies whether they're economic
policies or policies related to college
admissions or immigration or anything
else but the woke corporations seem to
endlessly want to push it on us and that
is what we are going to be unpacking
today and before we do let me talk to
you about Patriot Supply guys are you
concerned about having enough food to
eat in case of a sudden emergency
grocery stores can get stripped bare
within hours if you don't have backup
food on hand you might find yourself
relying on the government that's the
worst of all things don't let that
happen my Patriot Supply is making a
special offer to help everyone prepare
for what's coming act now and you'll get
a three-month emergency food kit plus a
free water filtration system so you can
have clean water to drink and cook with
you're my Patriot Supply three month
food kit gives you a wide variety of
delicious meals and it provides over 2
000 calories a day which is highly
important for keeping up your strength
and energy order today and get your free
gravity powered water filtration system
a 279 dollar value as a bonus gift the
food in your free water filter are all
shipped to your doorstep in discreet
boxes with free shipping included as
well go to prepare with reuben.com
prepare with reuben.com and now back to
me all right let's dive right into it so
over the weekend UFC had a big event you
may have seen some clips of it uh this
uh orange man who used to be president
Donald Trump he even showed up big
Applause from the crowd uh but I want to
show you a picture here this is a
lead-in so these were not the guys
fighting over the weekend uh this is
nigerian-born UFC middleweight champion
of the world Israel adesanya Who
currently lives in New Zealand and he'll
be soon facing off with next Contender
South African fighter driskis duplessis
now what's interesting about this is the
South African fighter is the white
fighter okay I guess that's interesting
if you just focus on Race about
everything right because you might think
Africa it should be a black guy okay
this is just general sort of NPC thought
anyway after the the fight that actually
did happen over the weekend Dana White
was doing you know the post game wrap up
sitting there with the media and the
media
as they are with everything they're
they're very focused on the racial
element between this black guy and this
white guy fighting and I thought Dana
White's response was just perfect and
this is sort of the energy that more of
us need when it comes to these issues
you know I know you say hey this is the
fight business people say nasty things
right but the tension between those two
and kind of the racial undertones and
all those things how do you play with
the racial under tones
trigger says he's the real African
fighter and so you know Israel dropped
some inwards in there tonight
so what was the racial
who did who dropped the racial Israel
was saying over and over yeah
he's black 50 in bombs okay he's black
who gives I was gonna say so you don't
have any concern about the way the build
up the tension between those two I could
care less this is the fight business
there's a lot of sign you can say
whatever he wants to say who gives it
why are people bitching about that
of course they are oh hey all right got
it yeah
too bad all right yeah last thing for me
I just love the attitude there because
are people bitching about it the
reporters some people oh not some
people are bitching about something
related to race also the beauty of this
it's the black guy who's saying the
n-word over and over right like it's
just enough we have all had enough of
this nobody if you are watching
basketball you're watching a UFC fight
you're watching football whatever hockey
are there any black people in hockey you
get the point nobody Connor are there
any black people there's a black guy
there's one black guy I'm being told
there's one black guy in hockey the
point is nobody cares about race when it
comes to sports people do not care at
all you care about if someone can play
can they punch hard can they dunk can
they do whatever kick Etc one black guy
in all the NHL geez interesting anyway
nobody cares about this nonsense and it
was really the reason I showed you that
really I have a few more UFC things to
show you because they're really sort of
they're the UFC situation is sort of
becoming very culturally relevant in an
interesting way but the point is that
the sports media does this this endless
racializing right the corporate press
does it with everything our politics
media does it with everything and you
know they're always doing it every day
on the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC so of course the big
thing last week was the Supreme Court of
the United States making the correct
decision on affirmative action saying
that race cannot be a deciding factor
when admitting a student or not we don't
want to say to a student based on the
color of their skin you cannot come to
this college because we've let someone
else in based on the color of their skin
well Joy Reid over at MSNBC noted racist
lunatic Joy Reid she's pissed about this
and she's it's not just about
affirmative action anymore for her this
is a blatant an attack on minorities
a really smart friend of mine said to me
this morning that what the Supreme Court
ruling in affirmative action proves is
that they're not against affirmative
action because they're fine with it for
like the well to do what they're against
is us what they don't want is people who
look like you and me in Elite schools
it's just not true it's just not true
but they keep saying it in a certain
amount of people keep swallowing it if
Harvard
was looking at the admissions right they
got a resume from a white kid and a
resume from a black kid and they were
exactly the same and every single time
Harvard admitted somebody they chose the
white kid that would be discrimination
right that's actually what they've been
doing when it comes to black kids and
Asian kids okay so it has nothing to do
with that nobody doesn't there is
virtually nobody in America that wants
to discriminate against black kids at
colleges or doesn't want black kids to
get the job or anything else as a matter
of fact at this point in 2023 America
you have every advantage in the
corporate world in the college World
across the board if you are a minority
right if you are black brown or a
lesbian or whatever the minority the hot
minority of the day is I can only
imagine what it'll be in seven years
right like you have every Advantage at
that point nobody is taking the position
that she claims that these people want
this was a good one though Joy last week
admitted that the only reason she got
into Harvard was because of affirmative
action
well let me just be clear I got into
Harvard only because of affirmative
action I went to a school no one had
ever heard of in Denver Colorado in a
small suburb I didn't go to Exeter or
Andover I didn't have college test prep
I just happened to be really nerdy and
smart and have really good grades the
good SAT scores but someone came to
Denver Colorado to look for me a Harvard
recruiter flew to Denver and I met up
with her at the Village Inn Restaurant
and did a pre-interview to get to route
to pull me into Harvard I wasn't I was
pulled in and the school's like
affirmative that I got into
affirmatively yes and it was literally
not saying we're going to take an
unqualified person and put them in
Harvard we're going to take a very
qualified person who we would never know
existed and put them in Harvard that's
how I got there that's how katanji got
there that's how Justice Jackson I
should say justice Jackson got there
it's how clearance Thomas got there Joy
doesn't realize it but she just made the
greatest argument ever for affirmative
action because Joy Reed who is not
bright seemingly knows nothing about the
Constitution or equality or any of the
things that America is based on but has
become crazy successful since being put
at Harvard because of her race and now
makes millions of dollars a year to
spout propaganda if anything that proves
that affirmative action is ridiculous
because we need better people than her
communicating the news from giant
corporations but she in essence is a
modern racist who's not that bright and
who got the job she's saying basically I
got into college because I'm black and I
got this job at MSNBC because I'm black
but it continues Sunny Hosten over at
the view do we have a warning for the
good people Sonny Hosten over at the
view is very very concerned she still
thinks that we're in 1940s America and
watch this
that the lived experience of a white kid
in Appalachia or perhaps on a potato
farm in Idaho or from Brooklyn it's
different in this country for a black
student whether that black student be
wealthy or not because this country was
founded on slavery this is such epic
bull what an embarrassment ABC has
done with the view this country was
founded on slavery the country was not
founded on slavery as a matter of fact
we fought a civil war to end slavery not
too long after our Inception there were
countries that existed for hundreds and
hundreds of years before us that
continued the practice of slavery long
after we got rid of it okay but putting
that aside so that's just a lie and
she's just an idiot what she is trying
to tell you let's go what she's trying
to tell you is that Carlton had it worse
than those poor kids those poor kids
what show is that again I forgot Little
Rascals right little little buckwheat
over there he was hanging out with the
white kids nobody was racist against
buckwheat look they they just it's just
pure nonsense she's trying to convince
you she's trying it's so sad actually
that's what she's doing it's so sad if
you're a 15 year old black kid and you
heard that from Sunny Hosten and you
live in Malibu right you're surfing
during the day with your friends and
you're being told that you are somehow
more oppressed in this state that was
that was founded on oppressing your
ancestors then the kid who's growing up
in rural Kentucky with next to nothing
and we're supposed to believe this is
this is real and honest
it's just pure nonsense and speaking of
pure nonsense Corinne Jean-Pierre this
woman man I I owe this I owe her cash at
this point for the clips that she gives
us here she is claiming that affirmative
action which is state sponsored racism
is actually a constitutional right
what we saw last week affirmative action
again taking away taking away important
constitutional rights that have been in
place for a long time let's not forget
this the president was when he was a
Senator he was the chair of Judiciary
Committee he is an expert on this he
understands how this works a lot of
these uh you know a lot of these
unprecedented decisions that this scotus
has made they have been held up in the
past by Republicans by democrats right
and so there's so much changes that have
happened in the past year and it is it
is you know unheard of it is really
wrong what we've seen now I get and you
get that MSNBC is not a place of
Journalism I'm not sure who she was
talking to In that clip but wouldn't
they uh someone that remotely ballpark
was in the field of Journalism or at
least pretending to be in the field of
Journalism if you're on MSNBC wouldn't
the next follow-up question be what
constitutional right is there to
state-sponsored racism you know this is
what they do with abortion all the time
too right I mean we played you a clip
last week of current Jean-Pierre saying
that when they reversed Roe v Wade which
just kicked it back to the States and
Kamala says this all the time they've
taken away a woman's constitutional
right so you'd have to show me in the
Constitution where does it say in the
Constitution or the Bill of Rights that
a woman has the right to an abortion if
you would like to put that in the
Constitution if you'd like to add that
to the Constitution we have a
legislative process that could make that
happen but it's not in the Constitution
thus in the case of Roe v Wade abortion
got kicked back to the States and
they're certainly that you will not find
a legal scholar anywhere which is why
MSNBC doesn't put on real people
you will not find anyone any
constitutional scholar anywhere who
would tell you that the right to
discriminate is in the Constitution
right it's actually the reverse of
what's in the Constitution individual
rights are in the Constitution equal
protection under the law is in the
Constitution
sorry I get it it's a Monday we're
running with racism you get it too I've
shown you how much the money that the
media is trying to portray us all as
divided racists but the truth is that
the majority of Americans actually feel
like Dana White that's why I wanted to
start uh with that clip the majority of
us are like so somebody said something
and that should frame all of us what are
you talking about what are you talking
about but with all of that said people
like Joy Reid are trying to pin us as
racists when we have actual concerns
right you can have a legitimate concern
about what's going on on our Southern
border and our immigration system uh
because maybe you don't want uh what's
happening in France right now or what's
been happening in Germany for years or
what's been happening in the Netherlands
uh with a completely broken immigration
system and people flooding the borders
maybe you don't want that happening in
America maybe we're being given a
warning from across the world and we
want to think about it and talk about it
honestly so we can come up with some
solutions one of the big things that
happened last week I think it was on
Friday uh Tucker Carlson made a a mini
return to the internet uh he was on
Russell Brand's Rumble show so it was
not going to be censored sorry YouTube
uh and they started they talked about
pretty much everything actually but I
thought this was an interesting moment
where Russell asked and you got to
remember Russell who's
mostly a lefty right I think he's he's
shedding I think some of that stuff but
he's also very apolitical in a way and
he's he's a brilliant
uh Curious mind I would say uh he asked
Tucker Tucker's feelings on immigration
and I think Tucker stopped it up quite
well
there are a lot of immigrants I love
including my best friend for whatever
it's worth
um so I'm not of course I'm not against
immigrants like that's insane uh but the
way that the United States is doing
immigration is designed to wreck the
country and to make it unstable and to
destroy any social cohesion whatsoever
or social trust to make people hate each
other and add to racial yes racial
division which I hate because it's not
solvable
um in contrast to say class Division if
we're arguing about class well at least
class theoretically can change I can
Ascend or descend classes but race
doesn't change because we didn't we're
not responsible for it we're created
that way so you don't want racial
conflict that's the one thing you don't
want and I feel that in the United
States our leaders not only want racial
conflict but are stoking it
yeah they damn well are whether there
are political leaders most of them on
the Democrat side whether it's the
corporate culture that's constantly
pushing all of this nonsense where
whether it's what we're being taught in
schools whether it's people that now
think that the United States like Sunny
Hosten was founded on slavery founded on
racism that our found our true founding
was not our founding that the founding
fathers were all evil all of the stuff
you get it but what Tucker's
specifically talking about there I think
what makes it special let's say in
America is because of that Melting Pot
that we talk about all the time right
the idea that everyone from every corner
of the earth came to America they came
to America really when I'm talking about
this I want you to think about your
family
think about your own family right now
think about whoever it was that came
over to this country from your family
for me it was on both my parents sides
it was great great grandparents on both
sides from Eastern Europe they came here
literally nothing tenement houses Lower
East Side just with the hope of living
in a free Nation no one gave them
anything
my grandfather grew up in a in a
one-bedroom apartment with six brothers
and sisters his father died when he was
one and then they had to move the entire
family to his aunt and uncle who had
like six other kids and then it was
basically 12 kids pretty much under 10
living in two bedrooms like all of the
stuff and your family has some version
of that right I know they do because
that's what that's how this country was
founded and everyone had a chance to
make it better for the next Generation
that's what I'm fighting for for the
next generation of little people who are
living in my house right now not little
people small children they're small
children who are living in my house
right now
[Laughter]
oh
I'm talking about the kids I'm trying to
make it better for the kids but the
little person the little you got it okay
uh but the point is what Tucker's saying
is most Americans are not against
immigrants and it has and and if they
have any reservations it has nothing to
do with skin color the question that
most of us are asking these days is if
you let in a certain amount of people
what does it do to our culture meaning
our culture is screwy right now we're
screwed up by everything we're screwed
up by race we're screwed up by the
entire woke agenda we're screwed up by
all the gender stuff and if you let in a
whole bunch of people who think wildly
different things and you do it just
because well it's America and everybody
should be here like what would you
actually be doing to your country now
earlier I mentioned what's been going on
in Paris and in France for the last
little bit and what's also been
happening in Germany for quite some time
in the Netherlands and some of the other
Western European nations but France has
a particularly bad version of this
because they let in hundreds of
thousands of people most of them legally
but some illegally as well well and now
these people are out on the streets they
are rioting they are burning down Paris
you're barely seeing it on the
mainstream media because it doesn't fit
the narrative but this video is going
viral uh this is a a French immigrant uh
well I'm not even going to color it in
any way this is a French immigrant
talking about why what's happening right
now in Paris is happening
racist
is
[Music]
a problem now I don't want to make it
seem like every immigrant in France is a
believer of what that guy said but
clearly he's saying like the quiet part
out loud to some extent like oh you did
something to our ancestors way back when
now we're here for payback what's
interesting of course is he's living a
western life he's dressed like a western
citizen he's speaking French right but
he's basically saying I'm here to
destroy this country
so putting that aside putting France
aside for a second all I'm saying is
from an American perspective do we have
every right to protect our border and
say hey here are the things we believe
in in this country we believe in
individual rights we believe that women
should be treated fairly we believe that
minorities should be treated fairly and
all of those things so you can't then
bring in a whole bunch of people who
don't believe not only don't believe
those things but that are also a tax on
the system meaning they want social
services and then it's other people who
actually get taxed to pay for their
lifestyle and then you end up in a
really horrific situation like what
France has right now where they're going
to have to decide the average Frenchman
is going and their political Elite are
going to have to decide will we remain
France will we will French culture mean
anything or will we just give it away
that that will be up for the French to
decide but here in America I think we
still have a chance to fix somebody some
of this but the machine isn't just
trying to divide us on race right we
know that it's trying to divide us on
gender that's the other big one that
we're having a bigger issue I think in
America than perhaps they're having in
some of the European countries uh This
is Wild this is absolutely wild but not
surprising a tweet from Kyle Becker here
I've had Kyle on the show a couple times
he's an actual journalist Michigan house
approves anti-free speech Bill incorrect
pronouns could cost you ten thousand
dollars or jail time before I read a
little bit of the clip you may remember
that many years ago now it's about seven
years ago when I first had Jordan
Peterson on the show right at the
beginning of the Jordan Peterson thing
look I even did Jordan Peterson finger
movement uh Jordan Peterson was around
against Bill c-16 in Canada which was
about gender pronouns and that you could
be fined or jailed for gender pronouns
he said that's the road we are going
down it is going to happen and everybody
said you're a far-right maniac you're a
bigot you hate trans people and
everything else well that moved forward
in Canada and it looks like it's coming
to Michigan here's uh some info from
Becker news the Michigan House of
Representatives has recently passed a
controversial Bill H.B 4474 making it a
felony to use gender pronouns in a
manner that another citizen disagrees
with under the terms of the new bill
those found guilty of such an offense
could face a felony charge punishable by
up to five years imprisonment or a fine
of up to ten thousand dollars the bill
construes misgendering as an act of
intimidation defined as a willful course
of conduct involving repeated or
continued harassment of another
individual that would cause a reasonable
individual to feel terrorized frightened
or threatened and that actually causes
the victim to feel terrorized frightened
or threatened the legislation explicitly
designates sexual orientation and gender
identity or expression as protected
classes the bill clarifies that gender
identity or expression means having or
being perceived as having a gender
related self-identity or expression
whether or not associated with an
individual's assigned sex at Birth
do you get it guys do you get it now
first off
hopefully Michigan goes ahead and passes
this and it works its way up through the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court
strikes it down you are allowed to call
anyone by whatever gender pronoun you
want to call them you cannot stalk
someone you cannot repeatedly show up on
their property right if they if if
Michigan wanted to defend people from
let's say hate they might want to do
what we've done here in Florida we
strict we tightened laws around property
rights so one of the things that
DeSantis signed about four months ago or
so was that he found that there were a
bunch of people that were going around
laws right so instead of just walking
down the street you know yelling n-word
at this guy or yelling you Jew bastard
at this guy or whatever they were
repeatedly showing up at people's houses
and putting flyers in their mailboxes so
he changed laws around that that's not
stopping anyone's speech it's stopping
it's it's strengthening property rights
you can do it in public areas but you
can't do it uh in someone on someone's
property right there was was a group of
people that were putting images of
swastikas from across the street on a
synagogue he said you can't project that
onto someone's private property that's
not stopping you from doing whatever you
want with the swastika in your own home
with your friends at this at the Nazi
party or any of those things but you
can't use you can't infringe on someone
else's property rights that's the way
you do it but of course that's not the
way that Michigan is doing it they are
coming after people's actual speech but
it's not just happening in the media and
it's not just happening in the
government it's also happening in our
corporations this one is wild it's just
it's just such an assault on sanity this
is a Woman by the name of Nadi akamoto
she is the CEO of a feminine products
company called August and apparently
she's making products for anyone who
bleeds out of there anywhere take a look
this is a good conversation for boys my
son is now 35 but when he was 11 or 12 I
sent him to store to buy a product he's
like ew yeah and I thought that's the
wrong reaction yes
some pads
it's just another product
no but that's what we have to change
that's the problem that's the problem we
have to change that some pads if you
must know but we so I guess to me is the
result of spending years in the space
identifying pain points whether they be
around sustainability like I grew up
hating pads most pads have enough
plastic for like three to five plastic
bags right so very scratchy very
comfortable but also wanting a period
positive gender inclusive brand so we
are August wanting a gender exclusive
name on the back it says we're here for
everyone who menstruates and I think
especially in this age of transphobia it
really means a lot to us to be proudly a
gender inclusive brand but everything
about the product we try to be super
thoughtful about from uh how we design
it to be as comfortable as absorbent as
possible but also as sustainable as
possible so yeah so with the water I'm
not sure what's happening here I get to
do a fun little you know we're living in
this one
yeah
good that's good we are living in a
society although I'm not sure for how
much longer that's George Costanza for
you the guys are testing out some fun
little things
um that woman wants to have a period
positive gender inclusive tampon
now I'm in the studio right now with the
three guys there's three of you right
there and I'm a guy
just by a show of hands guys is anyone
here bleeding from their vagina right
now
Brock actually looked down makes you
wonder makes you wonder uh you cannot
bleed from your vagina if you don't have
a vagina okay this has nothing to do
with transphobia although if a man
walked up to me on the street and said
my vagina is bleeding can you help me I
would be a little bit afraid I really
would be although I don't think that
would be a phobia because a phobia is an
irrational fear and if a dude walked up
to me picture a 6'4 dude runs up to you
my vagina's bleeding help me
I would I would have a legitimate fear
of that person so it's not even a phobia
they're just wrong about everything so
who is the who is the culprit it's not
the government it's not the government
it's the culture that is running
Downstream from our corporations why is
it that a a woman's tampon company
gets on television gets on network
television to promote her tampons they
could have put on a normal tampon
company an old school Tampa give me uh
Tampax let's say I was an old school I'm
a little out of the game Tampax which
was four women they could have had them
on that show and said oh women have
periods uh we make a product we've been
making this thing for quite some time
and we just want you to know we're still
making it I don't know it's got a string
and uh the whole thing's very disturbing
frankly but
they could have put them on but no they
chose this woman and her company
because she's anti-women actually right
she yeah okay you got it you got it
let's continue it's getting completely
out of control and more and more people
are waking up to it and the reason that
I mentioned the Dana White thing up top
and the UFC thing is there's something
going on with the culture around UFC
It's like because I guess it's somehow
inherently a very masculine culture and
it's about fighting and reality and as I
said earlier nobody cares about race so
you don't get into a fight like I'm
gonna beat the crap out of that white
guy or black guy it's like you want to
be the best freaking fighter period
there's something about UFC fighters in
general that they seem to be making a
lot of sense on this stuff and they seem
more willing to speak out about it so
NBA players seem very quiet about it
right uh baseball players seem very
quiet about it every now and again you
get an outlier there was that Toronto
Blue Jays pitcher who actually did speak
out about some of this trans craziness
and he actually got cut from the Blue
Jays which so they all have their
reasons right but anyway I want to show
you this clip this is from Joe Rogan's
show uh it's a UFC fighter he's a major
fighter his name is Sean Strickland and
they start talking about how
corporations actually are the ones that
are now anti-america
it's like this Unholy Alliance that
corporations are doing to America they
want women working they want lower wages
and they want more consumerism and it's
like I don't mean it like I'm not sexist
like oh put woman back in the kitchen
you know they suck and I love women you
know take off the burger we're
huzzah but but you know what I'm saying
but we're truly like in a weird time to
where like corporations are eroding
eroding values of America well they act
within their best interests in their
best interests to keep people consumers
and make sure that people just pay
attention only to stupid
you you have Walmart in the in the in
your phone now you want to go I mean I
can't even me I'm to blame there's some
times you guys where I'm like man I'm a
little depressed I don't know I'm just
in a bad mood I'm like I'm gonna go on
Amazon let's see what the Amazon fairy
is recommending me today maybe I could
maybe I could find something they'll
give me a little serotonin boost find
some happiness in a one click yeah and
then so it's like you and then you have
like and then on top of that now we go
full circle you have two parents working
and I'm going mostly on the west coast
you have kids dude Las Vegas graduation
where it's less than 50 High School
Dropout no GED I'm not one to talk
but how do you raise how do you raise a
family a successful family when your
kids are being raised by the system
right okay so the reason I'm showing you
that clip it's not that they're saying
anything that incredible or that
brilliant but isn't it much more honest
than what you're getting out of Joy read
over at MSNBC what you're getting out of
that CBS Morning Show with what you're
getting out of the feminine transphobic
non-transphobic product bleed thing like
all of everything that is coming out of
corporate culture right now is designed
to make us dumb stupid question reality
and everything else and then there's
just like a bunch of other people be it
Dana White be it this Strickland guy
Rogan what we're trying to do here some
other people that say RFK some other
people who are just like this is all
just kind of and nonsense to
Santas like how do we fight back against
it and you have to decide what level of
involvement you're going to have in the
midst of this whole thing and if you
don't think it's going to come for you
you really have to understand that at
every you can't just bury your head in
the sand on this one right you just
can't because it's coming for you no
matter what we've talked a couple times
in the last few weeks about this bill
coming out of Cali where they're
literally going to take children from
parents who don't do not affirm and I
use air quotes there because it's
actually disaffirming when your child
comes up to you and says I'm actually a
girl if you don't affirm that they're
gonna actually the state is going to
take away your kids that's just one
example check check this one out now
because you'll see how this is sort of
it's all becoming sort of like a social
contagion this is from the Washington
examiner 40 percent of Brown University
students say they are LGBT suggesting
social contagion right look I'm not
against gay people I've said it once
I'll say it again my husband's gay great
guy love him okay but the chances that
40 percent now it could be engineered at
Brown University meaning they're looking
because the kids are putting that
they're gay on there
Admissions and they want more gay people
there for whatever reason that could
possibly be but by any standard
deviation there's there'd be no way that
a college would have 40 percent gay kids
and the question is why does brown want
that right so they're going out of their
way to bring in more gay kids the kid
that's signing up the thing and saying
I'm lesbian I'm two-spirit whatever like
we want more of these kids which by the
way you could connect to the affirmative
action thing because it's another type
of discrimination if Brown is actively
discriminating against straight kids
which they clearly are then there's a
problem but there's also the social
contagion element of it that some of
these kids are probably just confused
some of them are probably just
adolescent it isn't to say hopefully any
of them that are happen to actually be
gay or lesbian will grow up and and be
in functional relationships and be
decent members of society and all of
those things so this has nothing to do
with going after the average gay person
it's about the social engineering part
of it colleges seem to only want this
sexuality and that skin color
etc etc it does not make sense but it
all adds up to what I've been talking
about here this weird cultural moment
that we are in right now right so I want
to continue on that a little bit because
one of the things that I think is really
uh important
is for a society to kind of feel right
not just get the policies right but like
when you walk around that you should see
you should see beautiful things you
should see good architecture right you
should see buildings that are an
expression of humanity and actually
Tucker and Russell got into that as well
and I think it is I actually do believe
it is connected to what has been so
broken about the human spirit that has
led us to what we're dealing with right
now
architecture changed completely and it
went from designs that complemented the
landscape around them to a kind of
architecture that clearly hates people
that is designed to oppress the human
spirit and make people feel without
value worthless I think if you brought
someone from the streets of Tokyo to the
Cotswolds and said what do you think of
that building you would say that's
beautiful because beauty is inherent
every person recognizes Beauty a Shinto
temple in Kyoto I recognize it
immediately is beautiful because it is
it's consistent with the symmetry of
nature Municipal and state buildings
were once plainly an expression of a
contract between the people and the
government of uh yes Faith relationships
I just thought that I walked up with my
wife in the rain on a village hall and I
thought whoever built that cared about
the people it was built by the people
who lived there for the people who live
there and they loved the people live
there because they were related to them
or knew them it was built by peasants
without machines yeah okay you know it's
true right what Tucker just said there
like you look at something beautiful and
you know it's true and then it and then
and you know it's beautiful right and
then someone else from a completely
other culture could walk up and see
something beautiful and know it's
beautiful it's innate to Being Human so
we we need to build beautiful things I
do the best I can within my house in
terms of artwork and plants and
everything that we have here to make it
beautiful so that when I walk around and
my team is here during the day they you
feel good you see good things around you
and you feel good and then hopefully it
adds a little something to your spirit
and then you can do better work you can
be happier and more fulfilled throughout
the day and and sometimes uh guys we
have to we have to basically
stop and smell the roses and see those
things and acknowledge it because we
went from neoclassical cities like DC to
the postmodern looking McDonald's on
every corner it does not have to be this
way DC once built beautiful buildings
and then it turned into these giant
monstrosities you got it you got it so
what we have to be right now I would say
is intolerant of a couple things Yes
actually intolerant we're always told we
have to be tolerant I actually think we
should be intolerant of the neo-racism I
think we should be intolerant of the
gender nonsense and I think we should be
intolerant of the anti-beauty that we
see everywhere think of every government
building you can think of think of your
post office in your town even here in
Florida and I never complained about
anything in Florida my local post office
it's an absolute dump and it doesn't
even have they have the string but no
pen attached to it why is that
so the thing is we must start saying no
to some of the nonsense one of the
pieces of nonsense I really want to
start saying no to you've seen this one
before there's a headline from KATV
they are all our children Biden
emboldens teachers amid debate about
parental rights we need to become really
intolerant of this idea guys they are
not all our children Hunter Biden is not
my son and my kids are not Joe Biden's
okay and we better start becoming
intolerant of that which is a perfect
segue to my friend Jordan Peterson
there's some other stuff we should
become intolerant of as well
what Tori what castration and double
mastectomies for 13 year olds seriously
man that's that's crossed the line that
is not tolerance
excusable silence on the part of the
majority the vast majority who knows
this to be
wrong in the deepest possible sense most
of the bloody Nazi propaganda that led
to the extermination policies at the
beginning of World War II were
predicated initially on compassion and
tolerance so this whole we're being
compassionate and tolerant it's like no
you're not you're aiding and abetting
the surgical mutilation of minors that
is not compassionate and it's not
tolerant
so my message on this Monday is to stop
being
tolerant of everything it is not a
virtue it really is not a virtue we've
got a great quote on the show today from
G.K Chesterton this is this is it
tolerance is the virtue of The Man
Without convictions
look you can figure out ways to always
be looking out for your neighbor looking
out for somebody that needs some help
but once you become tolerant of
everything you put tolerance at that at
that apex of the hierarchy of importance
which unfortunately so many liberals do
you will be the one who acts racist you
will be the one who goes after women and
who goes after gays and everyone else
and you will do it in the name of
Tolerance and that my friends is a
problem
but it's Monday and that means it's mean
me Monday over at the
reubenreport.locals.com community here's
the one I put up this morning Dad I
think I lost a bag don't worry I'm sure
it'll show up yes there is cocaine at
the White House we shall find out if
they find out who
put the cocaine there my money's on
Hunter we shall see uh by the way I have
to do one correction you know we like
the corrections during the show I have
been informed that there's actually
34 black NHL players 34 black ice hockey
players very exciting
that's what a feel-good ending guys for
a Monday show that's just spectacular uh
guys my full episode with Tamara lick
she is uh no I'm pronouncing it wrong
Tamara Leach is the correct
pronunciation uh she was one of the
leaders of the Canadian trucker Convoy
she came down to Miami so we could sit
down uh and she's going through insane
uh legal hurdles right now and fighting
the government and just it's really real
really wild uh you should check that out
it's up on Rumble and locals and YouTube
right now uh I leave you with a cold
close of the elderly man pretending to
be president and his brainless sidekick
and we will see everybody for the post
game show at reubenreport.locals.com in
just a moment look when I came to office
we had an incredibly high unemployment
we're in a situation where we were had
very little movement on anything going
on unemployed and I'm glad you talked
about the economy let's talk about the
economy
um what I believe we must do is continue
to be vigilant fighting for folks who
have a right to be seen and their
circumstances
because we have the ability to actually
alleviate the burdens that people are
carrying that make it come out for them
to get through the day or the month what
are you talking about to have an impact
on tomorrow
and we can't shortchange the
significance of that I don't know
whether people realize how much of a
burden this is It's cruel come on give
me a break here I was out to be a model
of what's going on here I don't
understand what's your the point you're
trying to make of a democracy to coexist
with an economic strength and power why
me God you can see this and aspire to
this and reject autocracy none of this
is worth it
we're having this conversation I think
we have to continue to elevate the
conversation
[Music]